this speaker somehow
has never had a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
i commend i don't know i love peanut
butter jelly you don't commit it but i
recommend someone to make it their whole
life without having that so please
everyone welcome megan
all right good morning everybody i'm
really excited to be here and be kicking
us off this morning the speaker section
of the conference
so
my name is megan robertson today i'm
going to be talking to you about
creating product production level data
science code so i am currently a senior
data scientist at nike um
to answer one of the most common
questions about that yes i do own a lot
of shoes
no i don't always get them for free
um i've been working in data science for
about three and a half years now and
joined the field after i finished my
master's degree in statistics so today's
talk is going to be focusing on a lot of
the tips and tricks i've learned while
working in industry to take something
from a proof of concept model
into a production job
so a quick overview of where this talk
is going so starting out with an
introduction
welcome that's where you are now and
then going to define what i mean when i
say production code or jobs
then we'll transition to
what i call breaking it down so how do
you take something from when you have it
in this proof of concept model or proof
of concept idea that works gets approved
and organize it so it's easier to get it
into that production form
then we'll move into some strategies on
how to actually tackle writing that code
updating what you have for that proof of
concept getting into production and then
last just a quick summary of what i
think are some of the most important
things that i want you all to take away
from today
so one quick thing to call out is this
um
kind of the dirty little secret of my
presentation is i actually tend to do a
lot more of my work in python this
presentation isn't necessarily r
specific um
so if you are looking for our specific
resources about packages different
functions that exist already to put your
r code in production highly recommend
this website here put rmprod.com
don't worry you'll still get a lot out
of my talk today but it's more of a
general coding strategy as opposed to
something that's language specific
so let's start out by talking about what
is it when what do i mean when i say job
so
here when i'm talking about production
code throughout this talk
job is going to be the term i use for
production code i might use them
interchangeably but for the sake of
defining it a job excuse me it's just a
piece of code written to complete a
particular task that runs at a regularly
scheduled interval and
again this is something
that i'm going to be using
interchangeably when i say production
code so
for example if some refresh data on a
dashboard i'd have code that would just
kick off at a certain time of day run
without me having to um
having to go through and run things
manually at all
so
i wanted to then introduce the simple
use case again
this talk is going to be a lot of
general tips and strategies that i use
when i'm moving code from that proof of
concept into a production environment
but wanted to introduce a use case so we
could have a little bit of more concrete
examples to think about to make some of
those strategies a little clearer so
let's say for the next 10 to 15 minutes
i have left we're all data scientists at
a health insurance company and we've
built a model to predict member claims
each month the company has a special
program you get a fit
a fitbit you log your diet information
that's the data that we're using and
we're using that to predict whether a
claim is going to be made
and we also want to have in our job a
summary of the model and performance one
so the data science team can see if the
model performance is changing over time
but or
we also want something so our
stakeholders can understand what aspects
of our data what variables are really
influencing how the model makes
predictions
so now let's talk about what i call
breaking it down so how you take what
you've made for that proof of concept
which a lot of times can be a ton of
different code some things worked some
different they might be across different
notebooks kind of different scripts all
over the place how can you think about
breaking that down into more digestible
pieces for you to tackle to turning into
a production code
um
and i always do that by starting out and
identifying these smaller steps
so
here are three buckets that i'll
basically consider for every single data
science project that i do
these buckets can also have like smaller
groups within them
every project might not fit into these
you might need to add more of your own
but the idea is you want to sort the
code that you've already written into
each of these buckets so for example
like i always the first one is data and
feature updates so beginning of a data
science project you're doing a lot of
data cleaning investigating outliers
missing data
in our case we have diet and fitbit
information coming to us but we that
gives us data on like a daily level we
need to aggregate it to the monthly that
stuff that would happen in this phase
so examples of code that i would put
into this bucket include
joining together fitness data with
member demographics
a way to identify any bugs that i had to
do
aggregating those measures so we can get
it to that monthly level
the second bucket i'll usually consider
is what code did i use to develop the
model or run whatever algorithm it is
that i'm using
so for example let's say in our use case
we want to refit update the parameters
of our model every two months that code
goes into this bucket we want to predict
which customers will make a claim that
also goes into this bucket as well as
saving those model outputs
and then the final bucket is some sort
of sharing or automated reporting again
not every project will necessarily have
this sometimes you just make predictions
save them internally for the data
science team to use
but in our case
we are relevant teams want to know more
information about the variables in our
model that are
really related to the probability of
whether someone is making a claim as
well as having that summary performance
report for the data science team
so
again here this is really just about
making the task of converting from that
proof of concept code to the production
code more manageable because now when
i've
sorted all of my code into these buckets
i can go to the beginning and start the
process of converting that proof of
concept code into something ready for
production which will be what i'm
getting to next and i just want to say
too that
for me when i'm starting a project
i'll try to keep in mind these different
buckets here and organize my code so
a lot of my experience i've worked on
teams we're using data bricks through
jupiter notebook type environment as
opposed to just writing scripts so i'll
make a notebook for data cleaning i'll
make a notebook for the model because
then i can think about how i order those
from that proof of concept when i'm
turning it into something in production
so now that we've broken down that code
and and organized into something that
can be a bit more digestible let's talk
about how you actually tackle that proof
of concept code and get it to the point
where it can be
something used in a regularly recurring
job
so
the first thing i always like to do or
define parameters so a parameter is just
going to be information that you're
providing as inputs to the code
so you can see here i've got two
snippets of our code the top one we're
just
making a density plot and ggplot to
display
the claim probability predicted from the
model on a certain day
so
circled in red there you can see that
there are two dates hard coded which is
great if i'm just doing this as my proof
of concept making some plots but if i
want this plot to be part of my job
that's a regularly recurring image
that's saved i don't want to have to go
through every week and go and change all
those hard-coded dates so that's a great
up that's an opportunity for me to
define a parameter
you can see in that second snippet of
code is where it's now changed to remove
those hard dates and you can see that
second line there under loading the
library we have a call to date equal
syst.date so that'll just pull the date
that it's being run that the model was
predicting for
and make it
use it to filter the data and into the
title of that plot so i like to go
through all of my notebooks as this is
one of the first things i like to do at
the top i'll usually put a cell for all
my parameters
how you change those parameters or set
them will depend on what sort of
scheduler you use so here obviously this
is an example where the date we can just
use system state currently that might
not always be the case you might have to
set up a way to like
for example another parameter you might
have is if you're fitting a type of
model and one of the arguments is to use
a certain loss function that's something
you have to define and change um
but again parameters give you a way to
easily update your code
so that you don't have to go through and
change like go through every line and
change it for every run that you do
another thing that i'll always do when
i'm writing production code and this is
i tend to do it a lot more in those data
feature generation stages but this is
something that you should be doing
throughout are quality insurance checks
which are ways to discover anomalies and
consistencies in your data output
so
especially when i was an undergrad in
grad school i
kind of operated under the model of if
it runs without errors then everything's
fine and dandy uh which as you know is
not a great way to do it and i would get
to a point where you know we're fitting
model and everything is null or
everything is zero and it can be a lot
to work back to figure out what the
issue is
so
these three areas are
i'll put what i call quality assurance
checks into a production code the next
slide i'll go over a concrete example of
what that could look like in r but this
is checking for things like null values
or outliers
empty tables if people are duplicated in
our data where they shouldn't be
and
this is really helpful especially if
you're using data that's coming from a
lot of different res resources data
pipelines break
things show up that look weird maybe for
some reason fitbit dies we have no data
on them or it goes haywire and it says
they're running 10 million miles a day i
want to know about those things ahead of
time before i get to a point where
my job is fitting that model and then
putting it in some sort of summary
output that's going to a stakeholder and
they're seeing all these wonky results i
want to catch that
so those quality assurance checks are a
great way to do that
so
what that would look like in our code
let's say here's just another simple
code snippet we're combining a table
that is unique on user right two tables
unique on user id one has information
about their gross the user's grocery and
diet another has that fitbit information
to measure exercise aggregated at the
monthly level
here i'm just going to check for
duplicates because i want to make sure
when i'm fitting that monthly model that
each person is only appearing once
so
here you can see that line total equals
n row that's just giving us how many
rows are in our data the next line
unique id is just giving us the number
of unique users so this is saying
a simple conditional to check
if the number of rows in our data set is
not equal to the number of unique ids we
want to exit because that's going to be
an issue we know this data should be
unique on that user id
and in a couple slides i'm going to talk
about log files and a little bit more
about information you can include in
this conditional to help you debug but
again this is just a simple example of
one of these quality assurance checks
and i like to start with those three
areas i highlighted on the previous
slide but you can also add more things
that are specific to your project or
i've had times where i've gone through a
production code job get a weird error
or it fails and i don't really know why
i finally figure it out and it'll
inspire me to add
different checks that are a result of
that error
another thing that's super important for
when you're taking
when you're making something to a
production job and this is even
something that you should be doing when
you're writing that proof of concept
code is commenting so i've only got 20
minutes a day i could do a whole other
presentation on commenting so i'll just
give you the short and sweet version of
it but
commenting is always necessary you want
to be adding these short lines of
explanatory text to your code so that
if you
come revisit it you know what's
happening um i've definitely been in
places where you i've got 20 stack
overflow tabs open trying to figure out
how to make something work you're
copying your pasting
and then you come back a few days later
and you don't know what's going on
adding comments um
will help you
kind of remember what you did it'll also
you want your code especially at the
production level for other people on
your team to be able to go in and
understand what's happening
that way if you're on vacation and
something fails
they're not pinging you to come and fix
it they can kind of go in and figure it
out themselves
like i said this
a lot of people have a lot of thoughts
on writing comments
i recommend if you to look up different
style guides so a bunch of companies out
there have their own recommended style
guides for coding about or for
commenting about what to include
how long they should be all that sort of
thing so if you kind of want to have a
more uniform way to how you comment
definitely look up those style guides
and lastly i'll just say
definitely comment as you code
you don't
want to be in the
the situation where you finish and then
everything you have to come back and
code after the fact is a lot easier to
remember what you were doing as you were
doing it
also on what i think of as the
communication front of writing
production job is the a log file so this
is a file that you store meaningful code
output throughout a job
you can see here on
the right an example of what a log file
looks like it's got some time stamps in
there it's printing warnings and errors
and
say you make your production code your
job it's running and then all of a
sudden one day
it stops it fails your log file is going
to be one of the first is going to be
the first place that you go
to figure out what's happening here so
you want to think about what are the
important information that i would want
to know when i'm debugging since you're
not there to run that code you weren't
there running that code line by line and
seeing the output in real time so things
i always like to include are time stamps
so i know when things are starting
finishing i'll usually throw a time
stamp on like after the feature
generation when i'm starting the model
fit when i'm ending the model fit just
so you can see if there's things are
hanging up taking longer taking less
time than they usually do
versions for things so if you're using
a shared like cloud computing
environment and
maybe something happens there's an
automatic update it updates the r
version packages get changed you'll want
to know what versions are being run in
your job
warnings errors are always helpful
because that can alert you to at least
the part
of the code that's going wrong i also
like to include data summaries so in our
example that would be just something
like a simple summary on the different
columns of the table going into our
model fit because then i can look over
time to see
is our group of customers
changing
and just kind of track that over time is
great and then
also
i like to include quality assurance
checks so
that what i talked about on those
previous slides are great to have if i'm
exiting my job because it failed one of
those qa checks i'll add a print
statement so i know which one it is and
that helps me hone down on the areas to
start looking for the issue
so last thing i'll mention
before getting to the summary
a big part of tackling the code is doing
code review
so
code review is just your peers are
checking over what you're writing at a
regular interval or as changes are made
this is another topic that could
definitely cover its be its own
presentation as well but code review is
great
because it gives you a sense of team
responsibility so
again i go on vacation i want someone i
want my team to know or someone else to
know what's happening in this job and
really understand it
it's also a learning opportunity so say
i develop this proof of concept model by
myself
but
i then need as i'm taking that proof of
concept code into production i'm going
to send my teammates small chunks of
code as i turn into that production to
look over they're looking at it to see
if there are any errors that they find
any suggestions any bit of feedback so
they're learning about what i did on a
more
detailed level which is great again
because that contributes to that shared
responsibility
and it's also a great learning
opportunity for
the person who's writing the code so
especially earlier on in my career i had
a lot of time for code review my more
senior peers would look at it and they
would say well okay what you did here
works it's right it'll run nothing's
wrong but like here's a much cleaner
way to do it using this function or this
package
so it's also great to learn new things
and here i just have the github
logo as a quick shout out
github is a
method of version control so i imagine
if you work in industry you've probably
heard of github um maybe if you're a
student you're not as familiar with it
but
that's the tool used most often for
version control and code review so if
you're not familiar highly recommend
kind of look we're learning about
pull requests merging approval that
whole process
so
in conclusion
a few key things that if you take away
anything from this presentation i'd like
you to take away
one tackle your production code in
smaller pieces so think about how you
can organize it in a way that's a bit
more digestible some production jobs are
going to be a lot more complicated than
others and it can be easy to get a
little bit disorganized overwhelmed so
think about what are the big steps of
your project how do they fit into those
three buckets and what order makes sense
for them to then be converting that
proof of concept code into production
always be thinking about communication
so this is where
things like commenting the log files
come into play
you
if you never want only one person to be
the only person who understands some of
your jobs that are in production people
go on vacation
people transition into new roles at
different companies you want to make
sure that you have that written
communication there so that someone else
can come in and understand what's going
on and then
lastly make sure that don't be afraid to
take a step back so again it can be
really overwhelming especially if you've
had to try a lot of things for that to
get that proof of concept approved
i'm a very visual person so when i feel
overwhelmed coding i'll literally go to
a whiteboard and just draw boxes and
arrows of what i think the different
steps of a job are and that really helps
me kind of get organized as opposed to
sitting there banging my head against my
desk kind of trying to figure out errors
or figure out what's happening
and
with that i think we might have started
a little late so might not have time for
questions but here you can see that's my
twitter handle um my website there as
well i've got a form that you can fill
out and send any questions that you have
for me um and thanks for spending some
time with me this morning
thank you very much
as a great kickoff to the conference uh
thank you for uh being that first person
if everyone had a great first video i
know we're just starting to get rolling